Would you say there's a steep
learning curve after learning one
to moving on to your 2nd or do concepts
kind of crossover between that?
>> Yeah concepts definitely crossover
because all the Frameworks are trying to
accomplish the same thing.
So if you figure out to do
one thing in one Framework,
when comparing it to the next
Framework you can be like okay,
I know in Angular, I can do x,
y, and z like this.
And if you know this Framework
the first thing you look for
is like okay, how do I do x, y,
and z in this Framework now?
And it's pretty straightforward and
luckily these Frameworks are very
competitive so
they try to compete with each other.
So they set their
documentation up like that.
Like hey coming from Android check it
out this is how you do this in Angular.
Or hey coming from React,
this is how you do it in this Framework.
So you can definitely bring stuff over
and I know from experience that works
because I actually tried to learn to
React while I was learning Angular and
I just didn't get it.
I was like this is kind of crazy.
But after I mastered Angular I
went back to React and
I built a couple apps in a day.
So it was pretty straightforward
after that once you learn one they're
all just the same.
because it's not so much the syntax and
how their Framework does it,
it's what the Framework
is trying to accomplish.
And you notice that all Frameworks
are trying to accomplish the same thing.
So once you know that you're good.
>> Okay so
what is some advice that you have for
students just diving into
the world of Frameworks?
>> Like I said there's
two steps of learning.
There's the practical side where
you just you know how to use it
very very well.
You might not know what those
methods and functions and
objects as you interact are doing,
but you know the result of them so
you know how to use it very well.
So I would say,
focus on that practical side.
A lot of people want to
dive right in and
try to understand how all of it's
working, the internals and stuff.
It's actually very scary if you do
it that way, especially Angular.
Angular is one of the scariest
Frameworks on the inside.
It is almost like magic, at first.
So I would not recommend trying to
figure out how Angular works internally,
at least, not yet.
But instead, get very very good at using
Angular, the tools that it provides,
and the only way to do that
is just build a lot of stuff.
Start off with a small app that
teaches you one example and
then eventually go up to bigger
apps that maybe work with servers.
And eventually you've built four or
five, six things that you can say,
hey, I've learned all
the concepts of Angular and
you feel pretty comfortable using it.
And once you get there,
then maybe if you're up for
it, jump into how it actually works
on the inside which is only going to
enhance your skills on
the practical side.